j'aime ton flow j'aime ce que tu dégages
j'aime pas de soleil ouais vraiment à
kate ont perçu 14 à 32 ans et bien c'est
vraiment des chars
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
plus migratoires sont censés être
contrôlé les ukrainiens bénéficient d'un
traitement de faveur par rapport aux
autres réfugiés alors êtes vous choqués
par ce qu'ils appellent à ne recevoir
que les réfugiés chrétiens en france
et on a mis ça valse qui était avec moi
influence euse bénévole à la croix-rouge
une jeune fille que j'aime beaucoup et
iajour messia qui est là c'est le retour
c'est le grand retour de jean messia
porte-parole de reconquête maintenant ça
y est il ce bac il a un il a ainsi battu
il ya deux catégories de réfugié si vous
voulez enfin il ya les réfugiés qui sont
de vrais réfugiés c'est à dire qu'ils
sont là pendant la période de la guerre
et une fois que la guerre est finie ils
rentrent chez eux ces réfugiés non alors
celle infligée la moi j'aime à croire
pour les accueillir à partir du moment
où c'est temporaire or l'expérience
montre que les réfugiés en provenance du
monde arabo afro musulmans ne repartent
jamais chez ea saison 4 où ça va pas la
leur au bar jamais chez eux la nana là
mais aussi rennes reçoit parti c'est la
religion bien
moi je dis qu'à partir du moment où ces
réfugiés en les chances de reprise ayant
daleux c'est pas des repêchés nie pas
des réfugiés c'est non non c'est pas des
réfugiés ce sont des immigrés c'est à
dire ce sont des gens qui vont rester
parmi nous c'est fini et on accueille
chez nous ne sont pas faciles et c'est
fini
donnez moi on accueille chez nous pas
seulement des gens qui peuvent vivre
parmi nous il faut accueillir chez nous
des gens qui peuvent vivre comme nous
mais
on fait comme ans de vivre ou de mourir
ensemble c'est aussi important les
serveurs que vous dites à la taverne
humblot a plus de chance de vivre comme
vous
le donner mais qu'est ce que fait qu aux
personnes attendait mais quel est votre
homme vous le découvrirez
ses bouquets taux longs
j'en ai encore une trentaine de
rencontres où la
mission
du crâne en ce moment vous avez des
blacks de couleur black au type de
couleurs pimpantes qu'elles sont venues
que trina ils peuvent pas aller en poche
et financer ses fonctions l'épreuve
qu'il faut donner qu'un ton
[Musique]
adopté par des français alors dans ce
cas
vous êtes combien de ces fous mais ce
n'est pas grisé comme ça ils ont des
passeports craignent un ba oui oui oui
dans ce cas elles peuvent passer mais
n'importe quoi jay z est asiatique
d'ukrainiens et on vous dit
extrait pour la france au cor et à cri
la france on est bien content d'avoir
dévoilé au contraire à si j'ai dit que
toutes les sociétés n'était pas bill
décide s'était pas vous dire ces
métiers d'antan sion allait faire un
petit tour vous allez voir ce qui se
passe actuellement je pense que vous
êtes vous êtes dans le déni complètement
je vous assure il ne contrôle même pas
les papiers et voit le physique du noir
arabe juive arabe est à la frontière
mais arrêtez de dire des bêtises à
jamais perdu quand vous faites honte
j'ai eu 90
sites où je vous assumez vous en tendant
à les îles bien méritée suite allait
justement jean vient en fait jean bien
moi je suis pas lassé de raconter des
conneries je vous assure mon épouse et
moi j'étais un test moi même chalet il
fallut trouver l évident que voilà la
carapate que j'ai et j'ai vu j'ai
constaté qu'ils ne demandaient pas mon
papier et disent ah non pas de
vous et allez dans une ville bombardée
vous allez trouver à la matière pour
tester ses légions vous accueillez
ya des gens je lis cette jeunesse le
public apprécie mais ça devient drôle là
n'en ai vu un homme et c'est vous qui
j'ai fait appel à mon ex rubini cas qui
a appelé tous les chroniqueurs pour
savoir s'il était chaud de faire un
petit resto espèces ou si ses fonctions
tout court
elodie yung ses rubis
coucou c'est lucas match a bien
ça va super j'aime ton flow j'aime ce
que tu dégages j'aime faire des soleils
ouais vraiment
et puis l'émission je fais que de
conseils trop en fait
7 6 à 14 8 14h36 de
l cat en 20 32 mois cette chienne on
fait comme ça
tempéré l'adresse
problème ok bisous bisous c'est vraiment
des charreaux
ruby à 130 kg resto avec sa petite coupe
de champagne oui elle a lu dans la
tonsure brown mais alors qu'est-ce qui
est un aimant de chârost bernese
castaldi vraiment
c'est de 10 ans et regardez bien comment
on a décidé de punir les chambres c'est
exceptionnel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
récit
[Musique]
les soins laquelle exe moi a réagi dans
la foulée il ya des gens qui ne
supportent pas le débat démocratique
l'auteur de lac serait le père d'un
enfant handicapé et aurait agi suite aux
propos polémiques du candidat sur les
personnes en situation d'handicap
l'obsession de l'inclusion et est une
mauvaise manière au fait onze autres
enfants et à ses enfants là après avoir
refusé de porter plainte eric zemmour a
tenu à rencontrer son agresseur mais
alors que s'est-il vraiment passé avec
l'auteur du jet de l'oeuvre charge donc
de sa voiture légère défaillance du
service d'ordre puisque celui qui me
tient la portière fait partie du sdlp
donc du ministère il est rattaché au
ministère de l'intérieur et il est en
train de serrer la main du chef du
deuxième cordon de sécurité autour des
réactions et il arrive c'est fou c'est
toi la rue
du service d'ordre local donc les deux
hommes en gros ou un moment et bien
d'inattention et c'est à ce moment là
car exe moore se fait écraser 7,9 sur le
crâne eric zemmour dit bon on va pas
poursuivre ce monsieur je donne parce
que
trois
alors et combiné truc moi à la place
d'eric zemmour j'aurais voulu déposer
plainte et c'est parce que c'est agaçant
il a discuté avec zemmour dit je dépose
pas plainte ainsi ce monsieur fait ce
geste c'est qui doit vouloir dire
quelque chose et donc eric zemmour a
fait sortir ce monsieur de garde à vue
et puis exe mot a rencontré ce monsieur
je suis a expliqué qu'il avait un enfant
handicapé que j'ai été choqué par les
propos d'eric zemmour s'est certes
inclusion des enfants handicapés à
l'école et d'ailleurs c'était le
j'imagine le sujet de l' échange entre
les deux une fois qu'il l'a fait venir à
son meeting à agen pour discuter avec
lui qui sont bien suivis vraiment je
savais pas comment réussir à parler donc
j'ai fait ça après il dit que c'était
une connerie il s'est excusé vis-à-vis
d'eric zemmour et puis ils ont pu
échanger sur la situation du fils
handicapé de ce monsieur france il faut
un rôle ils cassent à 9 heures quelqu'un
du court lui donne la parole à l'autre
hymne une gifle président du coup la
presse que donne la parole donc en fait
en train de dire elle s'est comportée
vous mal et où vous
c'était petit et que tu sers à rien on
s'en fout on reste entre l'élite les
hommes politiques qui restent dans
l'élite ils écoutent pas l'été petitjean
ils en ont rien à [ __ ] des petits
chalets rézé qui sera élu il
faut dénoncer toutes les violences même
les petites violente dont l'arrêt sur la
raison s'est passé par là je suis
d'accord mais pour avoir discuté avec ce
monsieur pour avoir entendu la
conversation entre eric zemmour est ce
monsieur n'à réf j'ai vraiment envie
d'aller sur gm et ça c'est parce que
désolé mais je fais des violet
maintenant je suis désolé aux portes
mais peu dur au parc des moulins il faut
qu'il soit condamné comme le gamin qui
avait mis une prime de plaques au
président catherine
prison je suis désolé yahia ben yahia
lord il ya des choses ya des règles et
au delà de l'humanité on ne dit pas
quelque chose en frappant ya des vols
ont fait des choses pour ça je suis
désolé là il ya ce qu'a fait eric
zemmour et bien c'est très bien alors
il peut frapper tous les candidats les
petits cela est tout le temps à insulter
qui s'est ouverte dans la partie je ne
justifie pas les violences et proposez
vous comme les bonnes questions sur vos
propos qui sont extrêmes et la langue et
de bons cela rendait sur la carlingue
dans la figure guérir tous les commerces
c'est quoi la limite entre 1,9 et
pourquoi pas la prochaine fois je sais
pas d'accord avec moi pour américain
allons-y mais moi je rejoins ce que tu
dis puisque en fait c'est le seul moyen
de se faire entendre pour ces gens là un
moteur saddam eternal est d'accord ce
cas la dengue sous prétexte que les gens
sont âgés ils peuvent frapper les gens
ils merci insulté alors trop faire je
l'avais déjà dit avec les années on
m'avait tuer pour dire ça mais je vais
le redire c'est pas parce que tu es
vieux que tu dois frapper ouvrir ta
bouche en fait c'est comme les autres tu
es jeune tu es vieux tu feras pas les
gens tuent les tapas et la voix leur
vieux combat t'excuser en fait les
excuses même si c'est un jeune hacker
bassil s'est laissé les mêmes
conséquences si c'est un vieux ce n'est
même pas 50 albums
on avait deux français fabrice et emma
que nous avions reçues avant leur départ
qui sont partis en ukraine avec deux
expériences qui vont nous raconter une
expérience bien différente tout est
parti comment par vos propres moyens
vers les rejoindre moyens financiers mon
véhicule personnel adacore avant que
vous avez fait vous êtes parti je
portier de l'aso de la france je m'en
étais pas l'allemagne la pologne mais
j'ai traversé toute la pologne jusqu'à
la frontière ukrainienne en voiture en
voiture incroyable et vous êtes arrivé
donc là bas vous arrivez en pologne elle
affrontera vrai la frontière ukrainienne
qui passe quoi bon tout simplement qu'on
a on a du mal à passer au début un donc
voilà on va dire quoi vous auriez vous
dit quoi on arrive ça va on avait du mal
ay terre d'un à l'intérieur du véhicule
et qu'on a pu quand même montré compris
qu'on passait à la faute chez rue
crescent c'est un peu plus compliqué
parce qu'il faut les papiers quand même
d'accord mais ça offre on a réussi à
passer assez facilement d'accord donc là
et aussi des tongues au dessus à son
passeport et sans passeport fonds
passport vous rentrez d'accord là vous
est alors pris en charge par un
coordinateur quilico coordinateur variés
oui moi je veux que tu veux battre à vos
côtés non en fait c'est un coordinateur
qu'on a sur sur un réseau d'accords
voilà il nous donne une adresse un point
de rendez-vous on doit se démerder pour
y aller d'accord c'est à dire qu'on doit
y aller par nos propres moyens jusqu'au
bout en fait donc si un problème entre
eux deux lula n'a rien à [ __ ] ccc pour
notre pomme paraît que là bas on dit que
c'est partir à la mort bien c'est ça
c'est le suicide c'est ça donc c'est qui
se passe on vous dit vous passez par
telma vous savez que c'est si vous
revenez pas quoi très peu de chances de
revenir il n'y a pas que forcément
important sur le fond juste un an en
tant qu'engagé volontaires ont perdu la
vie mais
je suis parti avec un collègue deux
collègues moi j'ai été refoulés lui
l'est resté
il a pas eu tant de porter une arme
permettant de porter un
l'équipe ans
il a eu un bombardement à hérouville
hébert il est resté sans porter n'at
il rien compris il a fait 24 heures 24
ans il est mort là matin le bombardement
a eu lieu à peine 24 heures après que
soit que tu appartiens c'est sûr il
reste avec votre collègue ben je vais
rester avec lui ce qui était prévu à la
base et imaginant qu'il repartait pas pu
être faire tu pourras que rien à faire
ici nos crus par ailleurs par la maison
et tu fais ce que tu as à faire des jeux
l'écouté
qu'est ce que vous avez vu la vague
n'aviez pas vu dans d'autres guerres
des paparazzi c'est incroyable et
paparazzi tout ce qu'ils y vont avec
leur portable pour filmer pour regarder
ce qui se passe pour qu'ils restent soit
vers la frontière polonaise où tu
rentres à l'intérieur et youtube aussi
ils connaissent pas ils ont pas le
danger j'ai juste faire du buzz
exactement c'est ce qu'ils veulent en
fait le gros problème qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ya pas de ng les
angels ne passe pas la frontière on y
retrouve on y arrivait sur sur le vivent
vous en voyez déjà envoyé les photos à
votre équipe il n'y a pas deux ong il
rien du tout on se retrouve on se
retrouve nez à nez avec avec un une
tuerie de masse c'est ça avec une tuerie
de masse on a eu la chance d'avoir
des gens qui sont dans la résistance qui
nous ont permis de voir certaines choses
et ils ont voulu nous faire passer un
message et on comprend pas pourquoi
des ong
qui sont richissimes
ne vont pas
excusez moi l'expression porter leurs
coûts et traverser la frontière et elle
est vraiment les aider à lviv
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de talent et on
est allé dans une école qui était
complètement transformée en centre de
réfugiés pour enfants et femmes on a eu
une alerte une alerte aux bombardements
la vidéo j'ai montré avec un peu on va
là on peut le mettre s'il vous plaît la
vidéo merci
jean melville dans une dans une école
qui était transformée en centre de
réfugiés de guerre et on est sous une
alerte de barbares demande ou deux
petites filles qui ont 10 et 11 ans qui
sont là qui sauront qu'ils se protègent
durant la phase
d'ailleurs comment ordonnance voilà le
voilà le refuge ce qui a été mis en
place par la part des bénévoles de des
bénévoles ukrainien d'une école on va
essayer de faire souvent peut aider ces
gens qui aujourd'hui sont
en train de subir un génocide c'est
incroyable ce qu'on voit les images là
vraiment des matches comme ça c'est fou
j'allais découvrir cette nouvelle
émission danse avec le roi du qatar
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sachez que ce qui va se passer là est
fait par des professionnels
surtout
faites pas ça chez vous bien entendu
voilà c'est important de le signaler et
merci à vous qui nous regardent et fait
attention à ce qu'on dit on est très
content de recevoir un ben moi aussi
leur est possible
j'ai un problème avec ça là pour moi des
partis au resto
on ne tombe pas dans ses statuts
voit comme chez moi fausses pubs et les
médias le public attend
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
candice est ce que vous pouvez trouver
les mots il nous reste trois minutes là
parce qu'après voilà c'est terminé mais
il faut il faut travailler
je te laisse que par le ballon tu
entends pas là la beauté je sais pas je
suis bloqué au dans le milieu on dit
veut frérot tu t'es chiant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu
la suite à 7%
[Musique]
alors énormément de gens ont vu à cette
vidéo
gi oh ça va trop loin elle est
catastrophique cette vidéo déjà parce
que alors du dip fake on ne sait plus ce
qui est vrai et ce qui est pas vrai il
ya plein de gens qui ont dans ces images
ça a été annoncé mort mais il ya plein
de gens ça fait peur aux gens avec
cendrillon un climat anxiogène et
ensuite je trouve ça extrêmement
maladroit comme manière de communiquer
c'est pas parce qu'un pays koné
l'horreur qu'il faut imaginer l'horreur
dans un autre pays avec un ton limite
menaçant à ces débats de sous-entendus
on nous chante lui mais c'est quoi que
ce soit si vous nous aidez toi voilà ce
qui va vous arriver je trouve que
l'image est d'une violence inouïe et je
pense y avait d'autres manières de faire
passer ce message cette vidéo je la
trouve qu'à barrières et vélo ce projet
n'était pas pour nous les attentats
c'était pas mal a rien qui est pour nous
et moi cette vidéo je laime bien parce
que nous on dit à l'ukraine bah
démerdez-vous maintenant puisque nous on
fait partie de l'otan et on a dit qu'on
interviendra par
bombardier vous dis que dans un an nous
à les aider si vous dis que ça va pas
arriver à les aimer pourquoi tu veux que
j'aille les aider mais non mais je suis
là dit elle
ouais si j'étais militaire est tombé le
diva j'y vais mais vas-y charlie brown
avait vraiment à 100 pour l'instant la
france la faune et la face à l'époque un
gain
exceptionnel non sur
salaire cautionne pas ce qu'on voit que
tu dis que la france ne sait pas ce que
l'ukraine ça ne suffit pas en fait la
misère qu'on voit sur le cren la guerre
on écrème ça ne suffit pas tu veux qu'on
se sente concerné en voyant sur paris
pour que des gens dorment encore sur
pourquoi les gens sur ce qu'ils montrent
pas encore plus les plombs en france en
fait tu as besoin de ce songe cependant
rarement la halle au grain ça ne suffit
pas de voir jésus vraiment ça tu veux le
voir à paris pour le réaliser bien que
ces accords avec cali p je suis
entièrement d'accord kenny le fait de
fictionné comme ça je vais pas dire de
s'amuser parce que c'est bas droit mais
de fictionné d'imaginer des scènes
terribles en france qui pourrait
malheureusement arrivé je trouve cedex
d'un mauvais goût extrême et encore une
fois je pense que le fait de voir ces
images c'est un impact sur les gens mais
en train tous tous le monde parce qu'on
a peur de la 17e on laisse crever
l'ukraine si ça nous arrivait un jour à
nous qu'on nous dise paris vous allez
attaquer mais par contre on peut pas
bouger parce qu'on a peur d'un tel jeu
te dit qu'on ferait tous des vidéos
vient nous aider mais nous aider on
serait tous club
oui la question que je me pose est
pourquoi paris pourquoi on parie fait
parce que petit nous amène enfin
d'accord mais pour être nommé m en outre
il n'a pas menacé de paris voilà
tout ça extrêmement
la maison
on reparle vulgaire là tout s'est
extrêmement et puis tu sais est
extrêmement arbitraire et maladroit et
je trouve qu'il ya d'autres manières de
faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]